[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's
thinking about batman forever and i
don't mean the val kilmer movie hey
you're having that now dc fandom is
right around the corner and with the
movie due to drop on the 4th of march we
have a lot to talk about in terms of
what's going to be happening in the film
there's also the trailer to go over some
brand new lego sets and potentially a
sequel that's right around the corner
some spoilers ahead so if you've got a
bat in your bonnet and want to remain in
the dark then i highly suggest that you
mr freeze the video and christian bale
whilst you still can please give us a
like and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns on dc fanimal next week as
you definitely don't want to miss them
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our batman
breakdown
okay so last week lego sets for the film
were released that showed some potential
scenes that could be happening in the
movie the first one i want to bring
focus to is bruce chasing selena on a
motorbike and this is a clip that people
were falling over themselves to film now
from what i've heard this will take
place immediately after the penthouse
scene from the trailer in which selena
breaks into the mayor's office in order
to steal a ledger containing names and
dates of all his criminal activities the
trailer opened with the riddler
murdering the mayor and this is because
his corruption and greed greatly
affected edward growing up in the film
we will learn that selena and falcone
are related and that she will very much
be about exposing her father if you read
the book the long halloween then you'll
know that in that a similar scene
happened with selena stealing falcone's
ledger detailing all of his criminal
operations she managed to escape and
batman chased her across rooftops but
here it's looking like they're sticking
to motorbikes interestingly in that book
selena set off on a journey to find out
who her father was and this led into her
own spin-off series when in rome in that
she tracked down a nun that was believed
to be her mother and slowly the pieces
fell into place for the reveal that she
and the infamous crime boss were indeed
related so that all lines up and makes a
ton of sense but take that plotline with
a pinch of salt as we won't know if it's
in the movie for definite until it
releases
interestingly on the lego box they refer
to bruce as batman but catwoman as
selena this makes me think that she
won't really be the fully fledged andy
hero that we know and love and it'll be
more of a transition for her that we see
throughout the movie i'm predicting that
come the end of the film that she will
pick up the moniker but that it won't
really be mentioned until the closing
scenes now it does seem that bruce might
even catch selena as on the lego box
there's an image of her giving up with
him about to kick the crap out of her
it's okay if it's in a comic book kids
now we can catch a chain lying beside
her and judging by the other toy shots
it's possible that she might be using
this instead of a whip to swing around
the city in the trailer she descended
into the mayor's office with a rope but
it could be possible that she has that
to get around more in this metal
depiction now next to that is a giant
gem and catwoman of course started off
as a dual thief however we also have the
bat signal there showing that bruce
might already be working with the police
on a more official level in the trailer
we watched as he was allowed access to
the crime scene at the start and there's
also a moment where he's in what looks
to be a cell or interrogation room
surrounded by officers he is eventually
chased out of this but the fact that he
was allowed to go to both places in the
first place shows that he's somewhat
working alongside them and thus a bat
signal already being set up makes a lot
of sense i've always been someone who's
preferred it when batman has somewhat of
an uneasy alliance with the police and i
love it when they turn on him as he's
very much a vigilante in their eyes
though he's useful when necessary i very
much think that there should always be
some descent amongst the police as he
handles corruption which the force in
gotham is of course full of therefore
they would have it in the back of their
minds that they might have to bring him
in too and it just makes a lot of sense
to me to have this set up now according
to blu-ray angel and big screen leaks
batman will not kill at all however he
will come very close to doing it the
former is someone who apparently had a
friend that attended a screening for the
movie and the latter drops loads of
updates and scoops on movie news big
screen leaks kind of gives it away
doesn't it yeah you obviously leak stuff
on from the big screen and again we at
the channel here are the world's
greatest detective now they both said
that batman will walk that line and at
one point almost kill one of the
villains the movie is meant to be taking
large chunks of batman earth 1 and in
that the dark knight almost kills the
penguin however alfred arrives and offs
him instead with a shotgun more like
oswald cobble shot gun hey heaven having
that one no i don't think that this will
happen in the film and instead so about
it i think it will probably be the
riddler who is of course terrorizing the
city now speaking of alfred the lego set
will also give us some of our first look
at what the character's appearance will
be in the new toys he appears to be
wearing a waistcoat and he's also got
long gray hair and a beard this is
somewhat keeping in line with the earth
one depiction and in that he was a
retired army veteran who very much told
bruce how to fight properly the
character also had a fake leg and bruce
swiped it out from him during an
argument because the guy has no chill i
would absolutely love to see a much
harder ingrid alfred than what we've
seen before and it would fit the tone of
this film really well in my opinion
annie circus is very much a proper
cockney block and seeing this more
modernized take would explain why bruce
is the way that he is in this movie as
he wasn't raised by an upperclass
gentleman in the lego sets he is with
bruce at the quote-unquote bat cave
which as we know from the trailers will
be a train station it's a pretty low
quality image but if we zoom into the
archway we can see the words weighing
terminus above the top and thus it
belongs to his family in batman begins
we of course saw as they built the
monorail to connect gotham and it seems
like in this universe that they did
something similar with the underground
due to their deaths it's likely
abandoned but it gives bruce the ability
to travel to most points in the city
without being detected one of the things
that adds so much to batman's mystique
is that he's seemingly a creature which
moves in the shadows and can appear
anywhere at once this would add a lot to
the batman myth and legend and actually
pulls directly from the comics in the
nightfall story arc the batman at the
time had his batmobile fitted with train
track wheels and this allowed him to get
around gotham at lightning speed
although bruce wasn't wearing the cape
and cal at the time and it was jean-paul
valley aka azrael they could pull this
across as it's such a cool way for the
character to get around interestingly
bruce ended up having to take the mantle
off him because he was so aggressive and
violent and potentially they took some
of these character elements and put them
into pattinson's portrayal now other
things to notice about the bat cave are
the fact that there seems to be a jail
cell built into it in the comics the
riddler found out who batman was but
never told anyone because a real that
people know the answer to isn't worth
very much however with this more
grounded take he probably doesn't even
care that much about riddles you know
the owl one's quite a good one but other
than that i probably didn't care and it
could be that batman just isn't taking
any chances and he may end up keeping
him in his own personalized jail cell
instead of taking him to arkham
something similar was seen in arkham
knight in which batman had several cells
in place to study those that had been
infected by specialized joker toxin now
the cell itself has the wayne w crest
above it and we can also see the red
light is wearing the zodiac s mask that
was first seen in the trailers
interestingly his ginger hair is popping
out the top in the lego playset so
potentially that gets torn open at some
point in the movie even more
interestingly they actually found out
who the zodiac is last week and it was
gary francis post it's always a bloody
gary isn't it anyway i wonder if they'll
have more allusions to that killer as
the mask and symbol of the riddler are
clearly similar for a reason now i
wonder if the riddler much in the same
vein as catwoman will turn to his more
classic sort of luck as the franchise
goes on and it is possible that a sequel
could be announced at some point over
the next six months according to super
duper scooper daniel rbk the sequel is
already being planned out and the movie
will tease mr freeze at some point
before setting him up for the next film
it's nice to see him to see him ice and
he's a great villain that i think would
work really well in the show we know
that gotham central-esque spin-off is
coming soon as well and in the comic
book there was a brilliant mr freeze
story that the police were heavily
involved in so they might be setting up
for that but after the movie releases in
march i can imagine that we will hear of
a follow-up shortly after it now the
next big look at the film will be shown
this saturday at dc fandom the mega
event is going to have tons of new
footage from black adam the flash and
also some big special announcements the
first trailer was released when only 25
of the batman had been shot so you can
expect to see a lot more to be unveiled
in this new look and i'm hoping that we
get some alfred as well as some bigger
sets and locales there was a point when
batman could be seen as he was about to
glide over the city and i'd love to see
a moment like this in the brand new look
we also now know that penguin is going
to be playing quite a big role in the
future of the franchise as an hbo max
spin-off starring him has been announced
it would be absolutely incredible to see
him pop up in future projects and much
in the same way that scarecrow became a
mainstay of the dark knight trilogy i'd
love to see the penguin appear in this
kind of role either way there's a ton of
things to look forward to and i will of
course be giving a reaction slash
breakdown on the new trailer this
saturday before doing a proper deep dive
throughout next week in the meantime let
me know what you want to see in the
comments below we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the mcu phase 3 boxer on
the 30th of october and all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want someone else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
what if episode 9 which will be linked
on screen right now we went over the
full things from top to bottom and
pointed out all the easter eggs we could
find so definitely go give it a watch
right after this if not then thank you
for sitting through the video yeah sorry
for the crap puns but i appreciate your
patience you take care of yourself i'll
see you on saturday peace